bonjour eric zemmour bonjour une étude
récente vient de nous apprendre que les
catégories aisées ce qu'on appelle les
csp + sont très largement surreprésentés
dans l'accès aux grandes écoles
c'est un problème selon vous écouter il
ya toujours on fait toujours des
rapports c'est un nouveau rapport à
chaque fois c'est le même rituel il ya
un rapport il ya des gros chiffres qu'on
nous sort et on nous explique toujours
que les catégories sociales défavorisées
en particulier les enfants de
l'immigration ne sont pas dans les
grandes écoles et qu'on a une sur
représentation à deux tiers des
catégories csp + c'est-à-dire chef
d'entreprise professions libérales
professions intellectuelles et cadres
bon et puis à chaque fois on dit il faut
étendre encore plus parce que déjà on
l'a fait le système de bourses et puis
on finit par conclure en disant mais le
seule solution c'est la seule solution
c'est la discrimination positive
en fait on s'interroge jamais sûre
qu'est ce que c'est que ce que tous ces
chiffres qu'on nous balance on fait
d'abord on nous dit jamais que dans le
ce qu'on appelle les csp + les fameux
deux tiers de représenter et bien là la
moitié en gros 40 concernaient la moitié
sont des fils de profs prof ma
connaissance c'est pas des nababs
simplement des gens qui effectivement
éduquent leurs enfants dans le cadre
scolaire ils connaissent les attentes
des profs voyez bon donc mais c'est sepa
sepa scandaleux qu'il ya beaucoup de
fils de profs dans les grandes écoles
oui c'est la première chose et puis
deuxièmement on nous dit la république
ne tient pas ses promesses etc
mais quelle est la promesse républicaine
pour la pause dont la demande jamais la
promesse républicaine c'est la
méritocratie c'est à dire qu'à partir de
la révolution française on a dit ce
n'est plus la naissance qui détermine
l'accès aux postes mais le mérite le
mérite scolaire
on n'a jamais dit que sous n'importe qui
devait être envoyé dans les grandes
écoles c'est romain c'est par un droit
de demander grandes écoles c'est le
mérite et je dirais même plus la fameuse
discrimination positive c'est le
contraire de la république parce que
c'est justement le retour de la
naissance même si elle est défavorisée
non plus favorisé dans
le cadre de sélection des élites oui
c'est un contre sens et puis après on
oublie que la promotion sociale a
toujours été lente en france
elle était longue pour les fils de
paysan saturday plusieurs générations
elle était lente pour les fils d immigré
italien espagnol et c'est donc ya pas de
raison que ce soit pas lent pour les
autres d'autant plus que voit bien dans
les dents les chiffres nous donnent que
les enfants de l'immigration maghrébine
africaine on souviennent le plus souvent
de deux familles de niveau socioculturel
très bas on a des sur représentation
parmi les élèves maghrébins africains et
turcs parmi les des élèves qui ne
sortent sans diplôme du système scolaire
donc tout ça n'est pas un hasard avec
des familles qui parfois et souvent ne
parle pas français qu'ils n'ont pas dans
leur culture familiale
le leu leu l'obsession de l'arête du
résultat scolaire voyez tout ça c'est un
câble sa propre petit à petit ça prend
du temps
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi on
s'observe et puis la dernière chose et
j'en ai fini c'est qu'est ce qu'on
attend de nos élites
on n'attend pas de nos élites qu'elles
représentent la société dans le jeu est
ce que ces grandes écoles par leur
sélectivité ne sont pas finalement le
dernier rideau d'excellence dans un
système éducatif qui est quand même en
piteux état a en tout cas j'ai fait pas
si l'enseignement et de qualité passe
qui aurait beaucoup à dire ce que sont
devenus les grandes écoles mais en
revanche qu'elle sûr c'est que c'est le
dernier endroit où il ya une exigence
une exigence de niveau de culture etc
pour rentrer après il y aurait beaucoup
à dire dans le loyer dans le cadre mais
en tout cas pour rentrer il ya une
exigence que que maintiennent les prépas
en fait ce qui reste de solides dans le
système scolaire français vous tout
s'est effondré
ce sont les prépas c'est justement ça
qu'on va détruire merci règlement